the guys covered this of Eric Andre like
every year for his birthday has a
birthday party that he sells tickets to
it's a show JD and blitt right you guys
win yes yes oh yeah so he rents out this
knockdown Center in Queens packs in 3
000 people the party gets set up like a
music festival with a main stage a bunch
of smaller areas to check out and then
he has things like a torture room with
people performing bondage and discipline
he's got naked guy covered in sushi
laying there yeah what do you do with
him do you look at him or do you eat off
I mean you could eat off him if you want
to JD was insulting to him and didn't
eat off of him which was I was a little
hungry the guy was offended the guy is
there you know with sushi on him and JD
was like no it's too good for him why
don't you want sushi I just got done
eating I'm not hungry come on just no no
don't be rude maybe later maybe later
don't be rude this guy here was there
soy sauce on his belly button you could
dip it on the side there's a guy with a
blow up doll there JD made friends with
him and the blow up doll in fact they
dance the blow with the blow up doll
humped it there was also a petting zoo
with goats and sheep and outdoor
wrestling rings for people who were
stuck outside an inflatable ball pit
mosh pit and lots of alcohol seems like
a recipe for disaster but anyways we got
some clips as soon as they arrived John
tried to take JD into the torture room
it was guarded by a woman with a
bullwhip
let's go I don't want to be dominated
I'm not getting whipped you're not going
to get away I'm looking back here we
could get easily killed I don't want to
get whipped it's for your job and
there's also security there's a big
person in the hallway too they're
allowed to go there I don't care I'm not
going back come on you got to be the
first to go no I don't it's for your job
no it's not for my job see Brave
you guys have kind of a sub Dom
relationship like you're you're always
like torturing JD then JD and Blitz
checked out the noise room at the Eric
Andre birthday party the room featured a
group of performance artists making
noise JD weirdly enjoyed it he brought
him peace
come on
JD fit right in
[Music]
why is JD laughing but like why has he's
he has a sense of enjoyment and love and
he he's just brought peace from that
noise I feel like that's what JD hears
in his head 24 7. yeah close close so
then Eric hit the stage he was carrying
a giant tank of nitrous
with a nitrous filled balloon he took
hits off the balloon while he addressed
the crowd we got a lot of drugs
everybody
[Music]
these are balloons are blowing up for a
party later
[Music]
priest in the toilet yet what about
Santa Claus did you see all the Santa
Clauses yeah we are handing out ketamine
prescriptions in the bathroom tonight it
is therapeutic we're gonna process all
our traumas tonight there's gonna be a
physiological change you will be
self-actualized everybody will leave
here like the dolly [__] llama
tonight come on
snack time everybody they're playing
their tits off over here come on
snack time is the name of his band yeah
anytime you hear that his voice go deep
that's whatever
that's the nitrous then to add to the
chaos Eric invites everyone in the
audience to join him on stage this was
insane this is was a nightmare for
security for everyone involved like I
mean it was it was pure chaos Perfection
come on up anybody wants to come up here
just come on
regime
those barriers represent division I need
to build coalitions right now the
promoter after that came up to him and
was like if you do that again we're
canceling this right now I'm shutting
the entire thing down I mean it really
was insane everyone was on this stage
yeah and once he got off the stage he
did a little more he jumped off the
stage did like a crowd surfing crowd
surfing and like they put him on the
ground and as he's walking out the whole
crowd just follows him it was it was
crazy in an exclusive John and JD
interviewed Eric Andre after his big set
on stage yeah
and Eric was in full party mode we got
to give the boss man Howard some [__]
taste bits you
what do you what do you need
Oh no I got Automotive nitrous this [__]
with sodium benzonate in and [__] how's
the show going so far I might not make
it I might not make it past tonight what
what do you what do you uh what do you
want to know AMA ask me anything how are
you feeling what is the feeling right
now all my orifices are wide open yes
I've seen you offered yourself to him
anyway yeah yeah I always offer you all
my holes I know you don't wash your bed
sheets but I offer you all my holds the
guy's got to clean up his act that's
your night no no I'm your wingman I'm
here to set you up what do you need get
him in I'm not doing anything no we're
gonna drug you tonight yeah we got a
drug unit no no no anybody can hear me
drug JD tonight just give them whatever
whatever he doesn't want give it to him
Eric as you know is a big fan of the
show in the middle of his big birthday
party he had messages for various
members of the staff
we'll be [__] up he's an
unprofessional [__] and if he was
professional he'd be here covering this
but because he's lazy he's not here you
have a message for Jason Kaplan
I want you to get big again I don't like
skinny Jessica you have a message for
Sal Purcell Sal wanted to rip his
[__] hair plugs out and [__] just
respect who he is you have a message for
Rich Richard Christy Richard Christie
Kansas City [__] sucks [__] hate
that place you have a message robot
Robin Quivers Robert Quivers is a
beautiful queen that I would make
passionate love to if she wasn't
secretly my mother you have a message
for friend Fred Norris Fred is a genius
and I want to play every sound effect in
my [__] mind forever and ever shout
out to Fred
blah blah blah blah
I'm telling you Eric's a genius he's a
mad genius yeah he enjoys He's very mad
Eric sang on stage through the night the
singing was more like screaming
especially when he didn't know the words
there's a montage of some singing
[Music]
that's the Rage Against the Machine good
for you
[Applause]
dada
yeah
[Music]
he's doing Whitney Houston
what's it cost to ticket again
what a party Erica braces the chaos he
he had like a prince impersonator a
George Clooney impersonator and like
they're waiting on the side of the stage
and we were asking them you know what
are you supposed to do on stage they go
we don't know Erica's told us to be here
yeah there's a guy walking around saying
he was the mayor of queens and he was
stayed in character the entire time just
not knowing what to do oh yeah he had
him puking and uh in garbage can
the mayor of Queens
it's your worst nightmare Howard Eric
closed the show by pulling down his
pants tucking his dick between his legs
and singing the Reading Rainbow theme
song on stage I don't got a dick
I don't got it I don't got it I can't do
that to snack time they're from Philly
they're gonna mug me after this you want
the Buffalo Bill I can't do that in
front of already I grew up in him
[Applause]
Happy Birthday
Mr President
happy birthday
[Music]
crowd going nuts
what a maniac
John and JD had a few moments to chat
with Eric later in the night he had to
be pretty [__] up by now oh yeah this
is what I was like having to sort of
hold him in place a little bit he's on
another planet okay what do you have in
store for 40. a quick and Swift death
you got any pills in your pockets JD
needs to watch needs to wash his ass how
was it crowd surfing it was [__] hell
on Earth
ah or you're getting groped I got probed
I got jerked off I Got Fingered I was
one man's personal [__] sock puppet
that sounds like a birthday party yeah
it was wild did you see the guys getting
fisted come on
okay boys good job covering that thank
you for sending us thank you
[Music]
[__]